بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
كتينو
هريره الصالحين
and
that prayer in the holds over prayer in
a home or in his
‏any
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
whyely
فهذا خرج مخرج العاده كما يقول اهل الاصول
صلاه
مسجد
مساجد
‏propengersجد
الحرام والمسجد النبوي والمسجد الاقصى
مسجد جامع
صلاه الجمعه
خطيب
مسجد جامع
مساجد القرى
مساجد او مسجد غير جامع
مسجد
صلاه الجمعه
مسجد السوق او مسجد الطريق
اقامه
people and make
passing through passing by be a rest on
a road or whether it be
‏mar right
air what have you tyes
in here
this in the in
it is moreous a person pray in home in
maret place anywh else other than thej
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاذا دخل المسجد
[Silence]
كان في الصلاه
ما كانت الصلاه هي تحبسه
‏is
[Arabic recitation]
cann until
as person
and
صلاه
والملائكه
يصلون على احدكم ما دام في مجلسه الذي صلى
فيه
يقولون اللهم ارحمه اللهم اغفر له واللهم
تب عليهصلا
الله
ما يؤذي
‏number
[Silence]
صلاه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الصلاه
اوكي ان قران سنه
‏ang
are all
the corre opion and you know we
صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله make
upon him
اللهح
الله
هو ذكر الله العبد
في الملا الاعلى
هو ثناء الله على العبد
والصلاه
‏slaves in
the heav سبحانه وى willa will mention
name will say my serv so and so i love
him you know will mention his merit
there in that gather
‏ang
other people
ask
الاعلى
صلى الله عليه
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الصلاه الله سبحانه وتالى
expلاص
الصلاه
الصلاه صلاه
دعاء
خذ من اموالهم صدقه تطهرهم وتزكيهم بها
وصل عليهم ان صلاتك سكن لهم وصلي عليهم
يعني يدعو لهم كان من ياتي بزكاته النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يقبل صلى الله
عليه وسلم الزكاه ويقول اللهم صل على فلان
وفلان اللهم اغفر له اللهم تب عليه هو
الدعاء الصلاه هو الدعاء تطبيقا لهذه
الايه
الصلاه
means دعاء
الله سبحانه وتعالى دعاء
person الله سبحانه وتالى
سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
mention
[Silence]
‏from over
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
صلى الله عليه
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان
ذا قران سبحانه وتعالى هو الذي يصلي عليكم
وملائكته ليخرجكم من الظلمات الى النور
‏ang in order to extract you from the
darkness the darknesses into the light
so the more person has Allah mention him
in that high gathering of the most
esteemed of his angels the more drawn
out of the darkness into the light the
person becomes نسال الله سبحانه وتالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر لنا وان يرحمنا
وان يتوب علينا وان يصلي علينا ونساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يصلي على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين وان يسلم تسليما
كثيرا والله اعلم وجزاكم الله خيرا ‏Ja.